et bin kim kardashian elle a dit qu'elle
serait infidèle à kanye west c'est une
information est complètement folle parce
que ça concerne le couple plus connu au
monde et on sait pas encore s'il s'agit
de rumeurs ou si c'est vrai mais dans
tous les cas on voulait vous parler de
cette affaire regarder les déclarations
de kim kardashian ça moi ça m'a fait
froid dans le dos dans tout le bas du
dos ils sont sans conteste l'un des
couples les plus puissants de la planète
elle star de téléréalité et femmes
d'affaires multimillionnaire lui rappeur
et businessman connues sur la planète
toute entière kim kardashian et kanye
west ne laisse personne indifférent
ensemble ils mènent une vie de rêve sauf
que voilà derrière la belle histoire se
cache des choses peut être un peu moins
magnifique
selon une source qui s'est confiée aux
médias s show biz kim kardashian ne
serait pas six exemplaires qu'elle le
prétend
selon cette même source elle
organiserait des rendez vous secret avec
plusieurs hommes pendant que kanye west
n'est pas à los angeles
l'un des prétendants ne serait autre que
le rappeur nick 1020 jeune homme de 32
ans populaire chez les plus jeunes si
kim kardashian n'a pas souhaité réagir à
ces rumeurs on ne sait pas encore ce
qu'il en sera de kanye west qui depuis
quelques années est devenue totalement
imprévisible
alors une question se pose maintenant le
couple tiendra t'il face à ces
accusations polémique
ouais ça alors ça ça là c'est
franchement motogp salut spipoll mathieu
de l'homme aurait alors les spécialistes
vous dis aussi que kim kardashian ne vit
que de ça de ceux de sa vie de se montra
de se mettre en scène de ce film est
donc détient tout petit baisse
d'activité notamment sur ses sites un
tag ramé ces machins elle nous sort
quelque chose donc là à mon avis le fait
qu'effectivement elle annonce qu'elle
trompe si ça trouve c'est même pas vrai
mais encore une fois cette meuf ne vit
que de ça que de ça que du buzz négatif
de l'anneau perso je la déteste
ah bah moi je n'ai pas trouvé je suis
fan après pour coincer c'est ma
référence absolue était sérieuse ah oui
j'adore n'ont de toute façon kanye west
et et kim kardashian c est ce qu on
appelle les power qu'apple donc c'est
comme par exemple comme les power
rangers mais sans cela c'est comme bien
de djezzy c'est comme les beckham et
ceara ils vont pas se séparer pour ça
c'est non mais là il y habite chez elle
il avait bien pu s'en est lui a mis une
sacrée affiche c'est que nous on en cuir
ses lunettes de soleil ça son regard de
bad boys
la touche est il que tu rester avec elle
la première étoile rigolo je peux te
dire que quand monsieur west va arriver
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça va être
chaud de chez west ham est le et
regardez il va être car il va en prendre
plein la gueule